[Music]
6
26 on your friday morning you know the
folks over at the nevada department of
transportation they sure weren't messing
around with a virtual kickoff
when they went
centennial bowling
so the virtual kickoff for the
centennial ball's final phase was
more like a kind of like a we are the
world for traffic
nerds it's exciting to see that the
centennial bowl
is taking shape and there are more
improvements yet to come
in this next phase this critical
interchange is vital for goods movement
throughout southern nevada and for
attracting new businesses
and visitors in a crucial time for the
las vegas economy
acting as an essential conduit for
supply chain deliveries
and attracting new businesses and
tourists the critical interchange will
ease the movement of goods and people
in out and around the las vegas valley
there's a lot of work to be done before
this last phase of the centennial bowl
is completed in 2024
and want to personally thank ndot the
entire ndot team
for all their hard work because we all
have a common goal in mind
to provide the best quality of life for
those in our community
well there you go very impressive
kumbaya moment the only thing i can
think to add is
please buckle up please drive carefully
and put down that phone
if there's something driving you crazy
you can email me traffic 8
8newsnow.com